the countdown clock on doho's Corniche
marks the final days hours minutes and
seconds until Qatar 2022 kicks off
now in the final stretch organizers say
they're ready to deliver you realize
that there's a huge excitement it was
building up over the last 12 years but a
hundred days to go you can feel it you
can touch it you can taste it and I
think it's it's it's a matter of just
you know The Final Countdown now
[Applause]
for the first time the competition is
being held in the Middle East and
there'll be plenty of other firsts the
first World Cup to be played in November
and December female referees in the
men's tournament and an ambition to make
this the most sustainable Tournament of
all time
Qatar 2022 is also set to be
groundbreaking because of this air
conditioning the majority of stadiums
will be artificially ventilated to keep
players and crowds cool
fans here in Doha welcomed FIFA's
decision to start the World Cup a day
earlier to allow Qatar to feature in The
Opening match the hosts will play
Ecuador albate Stadium on November the
20th it's a very big opportunity to
everyone here in Doha actually to to be
here and
to leave this all this excitement I'm
very excited to see it as this is my
first time I'm going to an actual match
so I'm very excited
100 days ago countdown events like this
one are happening all over Doha the
excitement is building for fans in the
32 Nations who've qualified and perhaps
even more so here in the host City
Victoria gatenby Al Jazeera Doha
well earlier we spoke to Sports
Marketing expert Simon rhines he told us
why the date change even by one day
could prove problematic for tournament
sponsors
it's useful to explain a little about
what sponsor how sponsorship Works which
is basically it's not just about the
perimeter boards and the and the
branding that you see but sponsors like
to do a lot of what we call activation
around it so they'll book advertising
create special events
um and one of the biggest impacts could
well be that the fact that they'll have
a lot of hospitality with VIP guests
coming in from around the world and that
could be quite disruptive if you move
everything a day forward it's going to
be very hard to reschedule
um hotel bookings for people even even
with 100 days notice you know if
everywhere is booked so that that'll be
very difficult
um also all the flights you know they're
going to be mainly first class flights
from around the world so depending on
what Arrangements you have for changing
tickets that could be expensive so you
know the costs could Mount up and the
logistical tasks are going to be
significant I think it's fair to say it
could cost millions and I mean another
area is is print if anyone's printed
posters and leaflets and promotional
material which has the exact starting
date of the World Cup then they may well
want to shred all that print and and
redo it so you know again
um some some fairly significant costs
as for the teams and players to watch
out for at the World Cup Brazil are the
top ranked side but it's hard to look
past the defending Champions France they
beat Croatia in the 2018 Final in Russia
Paul Pogba may miss the tournament with
a knee injury but they have Killian and
buppy and perhaps the most informed
player in the world right now Kareem
Benzema this week Al Jazeera spoke to
one of France's World Cup winners from
1998 David trezegay who's backing them
to retain the trophy
because they're the world champions they
got great quality individually and as a
team I see them getting to the final
even though the competition will be
intense the tournament will be played in
December so players from all countries
will be in very good shape but as I said
I think France will be very difficult to
beat
is the figurehead of the team even if
there's quality throughout the whole
Squad he's going to be the player who
will really show his qualities I think
he's going to have an exceptional World
Cup
beside France there's still Germany
Spain Brazil let's not forget Argentina
and Africa which is an upcoming
continent with teams trying to get to a
higher level